to offer comfort to those whose hearts
are shattered
I saw people getting shot and my first
reaction as a military wife was to act
and save people I didn't send people out
from the back as fast as I can
as the shooter was getting closer and
also my mother was there
and I also told her to not panic
and just breathe I don't know how many
people I saved the only thing that I did
was to act and breathe and start praying
in my mind miss Marcus was here shopping
at Walmart to purchase supplies for her
students in wadis when she lost her life
and another young man aged 13 who was a
student of Clint my ASD was also
back-to-school shopping when he was
tragically murdered yesterday and this
act of violence and racism and hatred
at a time when this country is building
walls the commissioners work here in El
Paso congressman will heard Republicans
and Democrats joined together to
dedicate an international bridge that
doesn't divide but joins our two
countries and named it after Marcelino
ser Nam thank you
[Applause]
you